yeah yeah no no don't do it
as for reviewing foodfight hello I'm the
Nostalgia Critic guy remember it so you
don't have to
every nostalgia we know I always wrap up
the holidays by watching one of my
favorite timeless classics Disney Sleepy
Hollow I grew up with it as a kid and
still enjoy it to this day with its rich
atmosphere clever storytelling and
ingenious payoff right out of a classic
ghost story which is what it was to
begin with so as you can imagine I was
pretty excited to see one of my favorite
directors at the time Tim Burton with
some of my favorite actors at the time
Johnny Depp Christina Ricci and so forth
bring to life the gothic tale of the
infamous Headless Horseman
my reaction was something like this what
the hell was that when the film came out
I had no idea what to make of it I mean
it looked beautiful and even to this day
I'm blown away by its atmosphere but the
story seemed totally insane it seemed to
have practically nothing to do with the
original and it pissed me off that the
kids version was more grown-up than the
grown-up version where's all the smart
stuff I was promised when I was a kid
where all of my confusion though there
was one question that stuck out the most
to me is this meant to purposely be a
bad movie you know along the lines of
say army of Darkness or even the Stephen
Sommers and mummy films what's this a
tongue-in-cheek satire that a lot of us
just weren't getting if so did that
technically make it better or worse
Batman Robin was a satire but we all
know what a classic blunder that was but
still it was hard to get a grip on if
this was even what the movie wanted to
be there seem to be a lot humor to it
Ichabod being a coward the obsessive
amount of gore and good God the greatest
use of Christopher Walken ever
if you're gonna have Christopher Walken
give him crazy ass hair sharp teeth and
only have him growl that is fuckin
ingenious but still for years I couldn't
get an idea about what this movie was
trying to accomplish then a series
called monster madness came around
hosted by I don't know I forget his name
but he talked about a style / genre of
horror films called Hammer horror I kind
of knew what this was but didn't do too
much research into it upon further
investigation goes a production studio
that got popular in the 60s that did
scary films many of them remakes of
classics trying to give them their own
60s and 70s touch doing so created its
own type of unique look and feel one
that could pretty much not be mistaken
for anything else seeing this suddenly
made me realize what I and possibly the
majority of audiences were missing the
whole time with Sleepy Hollow
this wasn't a horror film this was a
Hammer horror film a dedication to a
style long since gone reaching too far
you say trying to read too deep into
something that's not there well let's
take a look at some of the staples of
Hammer first of all the sets the sets in
Sleepy Hollow were mostly constructed to
be colorless giving a gothic and
otherworldly look that looks eerily
similar to the Hammer sets as well how
about the story it has almost nothing to
do with the original book Ichabod is a
constable instead of a teacher a
do-gooder instead of a selfish schemer
and he spends his time chasing a
headless horseman that is proven to be
real rather than just a legend or a
story the whole thing reads like a goofy
supernatural crime drama like well let's
not get ahead of ourselves
wait so technically two jokes
the Hammer films well they were remakes
of classic monster movies surely they
stay closer to the source material than
Sleepy Hollow did but when you really
get down to it really the Hammer films
usually took the story and made it even
less like the book than the original
black and white films did often
resulting in complicated plots that only
got more and more complicated as they
went into the sequels
much like sleepy Hollow's blood which is
so complicated you'd swear was a bad
episode of Sherlock
in fact even Tim Burton said you felt
like he was making a scooby-doo episode
half the time that doesn't sound like
someone who wanted to strike fear into
his audience as much as pay respect to
something he enjoyed even the actors
chosen hammer often had very dignified
British actors as both the leads and the
supporting here they filled the screen
in fact both Christopher Lee and Michael
Gough have been in a ton of Hammer
horror films Christopher Lee even has a
little nod here with these statue wings
looking like a bat fitting seeing how he
played Dracula in a series of Hammer
films for years well that the ricci are
certainly not British they both play the
parts pretty well of the bumbling hero
who must boil evil and the damsel in
distress who must be saved though to be
fair she needed a lot more screaming to
complete this hammer trope she should
have taken enough and Kim Basinger both
of these are the kind of main characters
you see continually in the Hammer
franchise the effects as well are both
kind of good and kind of bad which IV
effects in the 60s most of them are done
on set except when they need to take
something away like Oh a head and even
when they do you see G to add something
as opposed to take away it looks pretty
hokey kind of like some other layover
effects from Hammer the excess of
constant gore and decapitations is also
a plan how much go on decapitations were
in you guessed it hammer this is
important to note because in the
original Dracula and Frankenstein there
was nothing gory at all it was all the
power of suggestion but the Hammer films
knew they had to up the gruesome and
load it with gooey body parts and
severed heads everywhere again sounding
very familiar but the ultimate proof in
my opinion as I said before hammers
color palette often consists of a lot of
grays and even when they did have other
color they were often purposely faded
but in both Hammer films and Sleepy
Hollow the only color that leaps off the
screen because back in the 60s it was so
rarely seen in color was the blood the
blood was always bright red almost neon
nothing like what real blood is like in
real life it's pretty hard to find any
other genre that has blood that looks
distinctly colorful as this sure enough
in Sleepy Hollow
look at that when is the last time
you've ever seen blood that color in a
movie when you get at a costume shop
what's more convincing than that let
alone a studio film this had to be an
intentional choice because no blood that
you see in films nowadays looks like
this and for good reason it looks fake
this is something that had to be
specially ordered
somebody had to go to the blood person
show him or her a Hammer horror film and
say I wanted to look exactly like that
and that's exactly what Sleepy Hollow
looks and feels like a Hammer horror
film yeah it's corny but Hammer was -
yeah some of the effects are fake but
Hammer was - the style is still rich and
so many good actors come in to do a part
that even though gothic and cryptic is
still kind of cheesy again almost
identical to Hammer so wasn't
intentional to be an homage it sure
feels like it I think it would have been
the mother of all coincidences if not
but even if it wasn't it's pretty clear
the influence is so strong that it might
as well be this came out at a time when
classic monster film for once again
being remade with Bram Stoker's Dracula
and Mary Shelley's Frankenstein but have
you noticed there's no Washington Irving
above this title this was a Ford Coppola
produce film and he almost always put
the author's name on top of any remake
but nope not this one perhaps both him
and Burton knew that this wasn't a
faithful telling of the original it was
a retelling that only an over-the-top
stylized mix of goofiness and gothic 'no
scanning to life how fitting when you
think about it the same way Hammer
horror films were inspired by and retold
the stylist
monster classics now we have a filmmaker
who was inspired by and retold the
stylistic hammer classics no that's it
if you don't like the Hammer horror
films begin with and find a pretty silly
you'll probably think the same thing
about Sleepy Hollow and that's fine
it's not for everyone but nevertheless
it's important to know that there is a
very specific genre being recreated here
that was not just a work of randomness
it took skill to recreate this look it
took clever casting to find the right
people it took major practice to get
this film to give off the same feel as
the film series that's been practically
dead for about thirty years when he gets
sucked into it or not there are a very
careful hand that made silly scenes like
this this
goodbye Ichabod Crane I cursed the day
you came to Sleepy Hollow and even this
a little bit smarter than many of us
originally gave credit
ah I'm the Nostalgia Critic and happy
Halloween
you